the man has literally done the
impossible but now Tom Cruise's new
mission is taking him to the final
frontier welcome everybody to
Entertainment Tonight this guy he nearly
went to outer space in Top Gun Maverick
but here's the thing this space idea has
been on Tom's radar for a long long time
let me be the first actor in space
whatever whatever title I don't care
what it takes you know get get me that
ride I'd love to do that two decades
after setting space goals on E.T I want
to go to the International Space Station
it's on here we go Studio boss Donna
Langley broke new movie details to the
BBC I think Tom Cruise is taking us to
space taking a rocket up to the space
station and shooting and hopefully being
the first civilian to do a spacewalk
outside of the space station this is
where Tom would shoot a proposed 20-foot
movie studio 250 miles above Earth it's
very technical we're working on that
hard it's set to be built in 2024 the
price tag
140 million dollars so far there's no
title or proposed start date on the film
but Tom's pushing hard during the
pandemic he asked for a zoom call with
us and got onto the call and said guys
I've got this great project and and here
it is so the majority of the store
actually takes place on Earth and then
the character needs to go up to space to
save the day it's a wonderful story and
so we're working hard on that one on my
way
Tom who played an astronaut in the 2013
film Oblivion is a skydiver helicopter
pilot and a dedicated Daredevil who does
his own stunts we're constantly pushing
ourselves saying what what can we do
what's the next thing thank you for
saving my life Hollywood's Top Gun
definitely knows what works Maverick has
pulled in nearly 1.5 billion worldwide
but there's a question how do you get
insurance to cover a movie shoot in
space I don't even ask is there certain
questions I don't want to know well
director Doug Lyman says it's all worked
out we wouldn't be talking about this
movie if we hadn't figured out a way to
navigate the insurance component it's
not the plane sir it's the pilot exactly
foreign